so afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
and welcome my name is Alan Bernstein
and I have the really distinct pleasure
of serving as a precedent of see far and
it's wonderful to see so many people
here I know that we're all going to
enjoy the event later on this evening I
know I'm really excited about it I've
long been a fan of the gryphon trio and
listening to Julian is Rolla on radio so
I think these are 22 Canadian gems or
four Canadian gems Benny how you counted
and so I think we're in for a real treat
and see far fellows Laurel trainer from
McMaster and Robert Satori from a gilt
are two of the world's leading neuro
scientists who are going to present I
hope and I think compelling stories
about the science of music and the brain
and so I don't know about all of you but
whenever I think about music which to me
is the most abstract of the arts it's
always amazing to me that music can
evoke such powerful emotions in us so if
it's the volume of the music whether
it's a major a minor key the tempo it
can evoke happiness sadness anger and
it's puzzling I think at least to me as
to how that happens what is it about
music that stirs our souls and so deeply
the way it does for 34 years see far has
been canada and i think the world
primary mechanism for connecting and
convening the world's most distinguished
scientists to address questions of
importance to the world and through
those 35 years we have depended on and
benefited tremendously from a remarkable
group of supporters and donors
individuals foundations corporations
governments of Canada British Columbia
Alberta Ontario and Quebec but the gift
I'm about to announce is a single
largest gift in sea far as 34 year
history I'm very excited to announce
that the azrieli foundation has very
generously decided to contribute 10
million dollars to see far
the 10 million dollars is going to help
us not only support but launch two new
programs our new has really program in
brain mind and consciousness and CFR's
new as really global scholars program
for young research leaders from around
the world and so on behalf of the entire
CFR research community and I think all
of those who will benefit from the
research that these scholars and
scientists and young people will do I
want to express certainly my sincere
thanks to the azrieli family and to the
s really foundation for this generous
gift I know that our board meeting on
Tuesday on the board was really
extremely excited and pleased and
honored actually to be that see far has
been chosen to be one of the recipients
of this tremendous gift I think it is
important recognition of the work that
see far does in bringing together some
of the most extraordinary minds to
create a better world I never had the
good fortune to meet David azrieli I've
seen the plaque at the sofitel in
Montreal but I know that he was both an
innovative architect and builder i was
born in poland he fought in Israel's war
of independence and came to canada in
1954 the two companies that he created
can pro investments in montreal and the
azrieli group in tel aviv became leaders
in their field and have designed and
developed countless projects including
the very prestigious azrieli center in
tel aviv today his legacy lives on
through his wife Stephanie his daughters
Naomi Donna and Sharon and the azrieli
foundation one of Canada's preeminent
philanthropies the Foundation's many
worthwhile initiatives include projects
in science I put that first
education architecture and design the
Jewish community Holocaust commemoration
and education and if none of you have
any of you seen the books that have been
written by Holocaust survivors if you
haven't seen those books you should
they're amazing collection of memoirs of
people who live through and survived the
Holocaust they're just amazing and the
arts see far and the azrieli foundation
have I think many many many things in
common including a shared belief in the
critical importance of research of
excellence of the very highest
international order and the importance
of investing in the next generation of
research leaders the as reality program
and brain mind and consciousness brings
together some of the world's pre-eminent
researchers and philosophers from Canada
the US the UK Australia and elsewhere to
explore one of the most profound
questions of our time and of humanity
consciousness and the relationship
between our brain has two kilograms of
tissue and our mind as a concept the
answer to that question which is
sometimes been referred to as the hard
question will have implications I think
for not only understanding our brain but
also of brain disorders the azrieli gift
will also make possible another exciting
and important new CFR initiative the sea
far as really global scholars program
this program will bring together young
research leaders from around the world
provide them opportunities to interact
with other see far fellow some of the
world's very best researchers kickstart
their research with a hundred thousand
dollars of unrestricted research dollars
and help them develop the necessary
skills to become the next generation of
research leaders next week this coming
Thursday and Friday actually we will be
interviewing the very first round of
candidates who have come from all over
the world here it's a Toronto to be
interviewed these young people come for
full of over 200 applicants from 31
countries the final candidates come from
Canada the US China South Africa gabon
Israel Austria and Sweden so if if
they're half as good as I think they are
the azrieli global scholars program will
scholars will be creating a fantastic
global community of some of the
brightest young people on the planet
we're very excited about this initiative
and by we I think both CFR and the
azrieli foundation and it's all been
made possible by the generosity of the
azrieli foundation I'd also like to
recognize some of our other supporters
who have been so essential to the
creation of the ass really program in
brain mind and consciousness at sea far
brain Canada represented today by its
president and CEO inas Jebel / wallah
Nina's where are you who has has been a
terrific supporter for CFR and indeed of
all our brain related programs it's also
a pleasure for me to thank Richard MIB
senior who has been a long time and
standing long-standing an important
supporter for see far his daughter Roz
IV i believe is here with us this
evening Roz I know if you're here but I
could say well I'm looking for the IV
family has been as a group have been
such tremendous supporters of sea far
richard ivey richard ivey seniors son
has been on our board he just stepped
down last year I think forever and has
been just a tremendous board member I
also want to acknowledge the support of
the Henry white Kinnear foundation and I
want to recognize what is truly the
unprecedented support of Western
University represented here this evening
by their president and vice-chancellor I
me check ma and the Vice President
researched John Carbone it's really been
amazing to me how supportive that
university has been not just of Adrian
ml he'll introduce
but but I see far I want to thank all of
these supporters
but I've left to the last a special
thanks to Michael and Sonya Kerner for
their generous support of this new
program but in addition to their
financial support michael has given us
at least two other things one is he's
given us his daughter Jacqueline there's
a member of CFR's board of directors and
secondly it was actually Michael
suggestion that c4 have an event that
combines music and science and that we
should have it here in koerner hall and
a partnership with the Royal
Conservatory of Music an idea that
eventually led to this evening so
Michael we are I think Tripoli indebted
to you and to sign you for your support
for c VAR thank you very very much and
for those of you who have never been
inside koerner hall you are in for a
treat I think this hall is undoubtedly
one of the most beautiful halls on the
planet and probably one of the most
acoustically perfect halls on the planet
so before I turn over the podium I would
like to thank the great team at sea far
who have been working really hard to
make this evening a success there's a
lot of people involved as c far i'm not
going to read all their names but all of
you at sea for who have been involved i
want you to take one step forward so we
can acknowledge you and applaud all the
great work you've been doing well one
step forward Jessica I see you come on
who else